biden and democrats calling for stricter
gun control after the tragic shooting in
colorado that killed 10 people
including a police officer officials
identifying the suspect
as 21 year old ahmad alisa and charging
him
with 10 counts of first degree murder
authorities are still working to
determine a motive the gunman's brother
reportedly saying he suffered
from mental health problems president
biden not waiting for all the facts
before calling for
new gun laws you're going to ask me to
speculate
understandably it asked me expected
about what happened why it happened
and i'm not going to do that now because
we don't have all the information
while we're still waiting for more
information regarding the shooter his
motive
the weapons he used i don't need to wait
another minute
let alone an hour to take common sense
steps
that will save the lives in the future
and to urge my colleagues
in the house and senate to act we can
ban assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines
in this country once again we can close
the loopholes on our background check
system
the white house also saying the
president could take executive action on
guns
and senate democrats taking the same
approach as biden using
a previously scheduled hearing that was
scheduled for this morning on gun
violence to demand new laws
top leaders speaking out afterward
republicans seem adverse to even wanting
to talk about the epidemic of gun
violence
like the start of the covet epidemic
their strat strategy is to downplay
and hope the problem goes away there's a
lot of work to be done
and innocent people will continue to die
until we do it
for years we've been blocked by
republican leaders and their special
interests
now we can act and we will
get some reaction from everybody here
jesse can we start with you on thoughts
about
just reaction to the shooting and then
this immediate call for
legislation at first my
heart goes out to the victim's family
colorado just
abolished the death penalty literally
last year so
unfortunately this guy's gonna have to
be paid for to be taken care of by the
taxpayers there for the rest of his life
and
won't be fried in the chair like he
deserves the media has had a really
bad week covering death first you saw
the
spa shooter who used a handgun
that media narrative was that he was a
white supremacist
on an anti-asian rampage until the facts
came out that he was actually a
mentally ill sex addict targeting women
more than he was targeting asians now
you have
a muslim alleged trump hater probably
mentally
ill guy using an ar the media narrative
is gun control
then last three days in chicago
you had 30 people shot mostly black on
black
the media narrative is there it's
nothing
there is no narrative because they've
blacked that out so you could see how
the press exploits these tragic stories
disregards the fact divides us by race
in order to
basically control us and get profit from
that
i don't think biden's gonna do anything
on executive orders on this
supreme court or knock it down the next
republican president will knock it down
the republicans will come out like a
wave you've never seen before
if he does something like that they
don't have the votes in the senate
to do anything like banning sport
weapons
and this is what this is this is an
ar-15
it's used for self-defense it's used for
hunting it's used for target practice
and competitions it's light
it's easy to handle it's compact you
squeeze the trigger once
and one round goes off just like a
handgun
squeeze the trigger once one round goes
off except
handguns those are used in majority of
mass shootings
handguns are used in a majority of gun
homicides
media doesn't talk about that the media
is obsessed
for some reason over ar-15s just because
they look
scary and it shows how illiterate they
are every
time this happens dana they say well we
have to do
something even though that something
wouldn't have prevented
any of this it's just a really childish
argument i want to do something too
but i want to get it right first and not
destroy the constitutional rights
of law-abiding americans in the process
okay let's get your take on that
well then i'm just listening to jesse
and i think the supreme court has
affirmed
that everyone has a second amendment
right but
localities and states everybody also has
a right to impose
reasonable restrictions on gun ownership
in this country so there's no
contradiction
you know between owning a gun and
reasonable rules on who has a gun on and
even how
people obtain a gun uh
but the extremists you know it's just so
heartbreaking to me that we are still
having this conversation
you know children die in newtown high
schoolers
in parkland you know college students at
virginia tech and we just have the same
conversation because
the extremists the extremists in this
conversation say
oh no no to universal background checks
it's like 90 percent
of americans including gun owners say
yeah let's have
universal background checks let's have a
waiting period
for gun purchases let's have red flag
laws so we know who's mentally ill
who's involved with spousal abuse who's
a convicted felon
let's let's just do things within the
parameters
of the fact that we are a country that
affirms gun ownership
as a right that's all that president
biden and the democrats are asking for
and to you know belittle it to
caricature it i think it's not about
partisan politics you're going after the
american people here
and you're going after people who have
been you know all of us are a danger
from these kind of
you know from the fact that the
country's awash in guns and it gets into
the hands of irresponsible
people okay so it's another point of
view and kennedy
let's get your thoughts on this today
well there are a couple things here
um it's interesting that juan is talking
about using mental illness which you
know if you're saying that the blanket
term mental illness will be the metric
by which you ban people from owning guns
uh that only further stigmatizes mental
illness
and that means you know if you have a
single mom in a big city
uh who has been treated for mental
illness maybe anxiety or depression
who wants to defend herself maybe she's
not going to seek
treatment because she doesn't want to be
put on some kind of a list
where she wouldn't be able to own a
firearm in order to defend her family
maybe you have uh someone who is truly
deeply mentally ill
who he now sees that this entire
condition has been stigmatized
who doesn't go for treatment and this is
this is what we see
over and over again with these shootings
it is a sociopathy it is a mental
illness it is the isolation
it is the hate and somehow we're not
identifying those things
in an effective way so people actually
get treatment
and i think part of that is because of
the stigma
now in places like portland oregon you
have a city that has been under siege
a d.a who won't prosecute violent
criminals so people feel that
you know in a city where police are
absolutely hated and they talk about
defunding and police are racist
then people feel they have no other
choice than to get a firearm to defend
themselves
because those sort of riots have been
spreading out into
the suburbs and it's it becomes very
authoritarian
it squashes civil liberties and we never
get to the heart of the problem
one which is sociopathy and hate and
when you can
tackle that honestly and realistically
i'm willing to listen to the rest of it